walking to this video 45 minute game and
this is some with the new board layout a
couple of days the last couple of days
head to the old layout or let said
interim layout why I was trying with the
coordinates but this wouldn't frame then
really didn't really am God much love
from the front of us which in a way I
understand it sir it's um it was a bit
weird and but I really like this one so
I'm going to continue with this okay we
got we got a chick arena mm-hmm Queens
gambit chivalry and yeah I'm not sure
here that's I am I don't have any
substantial experience with this
particular line I normally played the
chicken so in some other way as so I ok
I took on on d5 early which is not my my
normal way to play i'm not quite sure
why i went for this it's nothing
terribly bad it just just feels a bit
dumb a bit strange here ok my ideas so
take on c5 and try to grab the porn on
17 on the sir ansi hive takes and rugby
5 foot and the OS has got Ruby age yeah
I think
now I development is not so great really
and he's got seasick 70 this position is
probably quite okay for black that looks
on that looks recent I'm not quite sure
what you should do though it's not not
so easy I still have this idea to take a
plane would be five winning the porn but
I didn't want to do that right away as
he has had rook v8 and yeah I have no
development on the King side so I want
to at least have quick and the
possibility to connect the rooks quickly
so if i do that now here now I wonder if
short castles or so can be can be
dangerous to me maybe made dangerous for
me not to me like rook f6 and so on but
I'm not sure I mean yes this is of
course also possible the night may be
coming to f5 and that's always the Queen
okay so i want to i don't want the night
to appear on f5 that's not not what I
want okay question is how quick is this
this is a tech on the King side there is
there is some merit to that I'd like to
get in at least root g one rock g1 g2
Luke g1 also allows maybe route bishop f
12 h 3 which could be in a nice way to
activate the tuba shop I could have gone
to age three anyway instead of Bishop e2
but I couldn't really do this tactically
because there was always 93 and and then
I wanted to wanted to keep this a bit
a bit more solid um what exactly is the
threat here 27 to h3 maybe now i have
not quite sure okay yeah now i can
actually grab here and i think i will do
that you can give this check and so on
but i will go to f 181 and if i get c5
the queenside will remain weak it's not
just like I get a pawn and have problems
I hope I'm judging this right yeah look
c5 it is a bit of a self pin but i have
5 root a 5 all the time so I don't think
it's a problem okay no he wants to check
check but I go to f1 now and I wonder I
wonder actually if i should go Quinn a 5
just attack the pawn here if we might
play c6 though
we can probably take that yeah i'm not
sure i think i prefer this after all
directly trying to get the Queen's off
Oh interesting this side I didn't didn't
take into consideration at all trying to
go to be one I mean II seven is hanging
but interesting
c5 I want to check and here and have to
hang so wow that let that can get tricky
so I must play this right let's really
no other it cost me quite some time to
to realize that not very good yeah my
king position is still a bit shaky I'm
not sure it could be that white is just
excellent but it could also be that here
this attack gets tricky it's very very
much possible look aged 6 threatening to
take on h2 wow this this alone it could
be a very problematic yeah in fact he
can do that right hook h6 is very strong
threatening to take Rock h6 and Queen g6
checkmate not even sure what I do
against that yeah well it was a bit
what's the am I wasn't a bit of a panic
mode already after yeah that that's a
simple threat I morning I don't see how
to how to how to combat that really
and take here it's just it's just made
it's just a check made ok I don't I
don't see him with absolutely no move
what do i do after Luke takes it was
just the only thing that I spotted queen
bee three c5 Heather's still this is
kind of mechanism I can take on f2 would
she took Winnie one check yeah that was
simply too dangerous Jack yeah this is
also when okay learning yeah he had too
much counter play here i'm pretty sure
that route here it should be fine for me
but i didn't play a good defense right
here the computer agrees giving why the
clear edge but i must made something
here this is probably not great computer
still likes it the computer is pretty
pretty good in this concrete position
okay wants to take but not that uh-huh
but to Queen a five or look be seven
what was the real problem of all that I
took here gave six probably this one
yeah this one yeah it Queen B 6 is
already win for black that's quite
remarkable
yeah bouquet five looks totally normal
but it's not really working amazing
Queen B 6 was worth spotted not exactly
okay well watch what else I cannot allow
the Queen trade so I was about to say
it's a good move well well spotted but
what else would you do pretty much
forced him to win what answers that I
can take and and continue here that the
computer likes yeah it still fields Ted
shaking between a five Queen f6 and
Queenie one yeah that's very tricky to
play on in with a long time the computer
is giving why the straight we fled win
just winning but not quite sure I mean
maybe it is right by the engine but it's
it's very difficult to play I am now a
computer gives this kind of maneuver
interesting yeah very tough to play so
when he made very good time he initiated
a very good counter play right thanks
for watching